foreign
here's an extended quote from the
Brookings Institute research
yet apart from these conspiracy theories
unsubstantiated or false claims shared
at this time were far more nuanced and
primarily involved wait for it
misunderstandings of science
yeah it's quite a client several several
prominent podcasters carved out
positions of authority during this
period of high uncertainty for example
Heather high and Brett Weinstein that's
us relied on their backgrounds in
evolutionary biology to amass a white
audience for their unconventional
coronavirus advice the pair repeated
unproven claims about the prophylactic
use of various treatments including
Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine and
cast doubt on vaccine safety
throughout their episodes high in
Weinstein tried to bolster perceptions
of their credentials by using technical
terms
in one episode Weinstein offered a
little brain teaser saying that quote
correlation is in fact evidence of
causation if there was a causal
hypothesis pre-existing the observation
of the correlation end quote
I can't even read this next part with a
straight face while it's unclear exactly
what he is referencing
perhaps the most basic tentative
statistics emphasizes that correlation
does not equal causation isn't and is
indeed susceptible to confounders
although researchers can control for
potential known confounders there may be
infinitely more unknown confounding
variables driving any absurd
relationship rather than protecting
researchers against confounding a
pre-existing hypothesis may instead make
them more prone to confirmation bias
Weinstein however may have deployed this
language to appear to burnish the
scientific Bona fides of the hosts for a
non-technical audience
you know who's trying to burnish your
scientific Bona fides for the benefit of
a non-technical audience that's you
Brookings Institute and the New York
Times and all the rest of you you
clearly have no idea what you're doing
you don't understand what a hypothesis
is and that prediction
changes
Baseline oh my God this is so bad I'm
sorry like let me just finish read like
this is so bad okay go on they have
eaten so bad invalidated most of Science
in their claim because what they've done
is ruled out the possibility that you
could test an idea by making a
prediction and then seeing whether the
correlation exists if this is true you
can't know anything ever there is no
knowledge there's no basis to know
anything what's more the very things
that they are claiming that we the most
basic tentative statistics right but so
this is a classic this is a classic
um mid-wit idiocy yeah right because the
point is
um
you come to a level of understanding
which is correlation does not imply
causation which is shorthand for
correlation alone does not imply
causation our brain teaser was yes it
does imply causation when you
hypothesize that there would be a
correlation the evidence is all the
stronger if it is an unexpected
correlation predicted only by that
hypothesis and then lo and behold you
find it so the point is these people are
non-scientists
misunderstanding what actual science is
and deploying this syllogism without an
understanding of what it even means and
if I mean I guess you I will finish the
rest of this in a minute it's like you
can take this off the screen for the
moment um if
if the author of this report
is willing to say
I don't even know what this means
but we all know don't we the correlation
doesn't play causation
why is it that we are supposed to take
anything that this person says or that
the people who rely on this kind of
analysis
with any kind of seriousness like this
is a demonstration of a failure to
understand
basic scientific logic right that's so
basically the most fundamental the most
fun which is that we we you know your
observation of a pattern is not a
scientific conclusion you have to get to
a hypothesis about what might cause the
pattern then you have to test that with
a prediction right that's how you
discover this thing and so even well
there's your own report should collapse
under this because the whole idea that
anybody knows what's true about covid
and therefore that we can say that those
other things must be false that comes
from work in which people have deployed
a hypothesis and then look for a
correlation
to be fair to these people which I think
were being very very fair but um they're
not alone
I remember back when we were professors
and I would get asked to peer review
papers
for journals because this is an
expectation this is part of the unpaid
work of being
a professors that you get asked to peer
review papers for various journals and
the the most frequent
reason that I gave to reject a paper
was
there's no hypothesis
the authors want to reframe this as
we collected a bunch of information and
from that made an observation and now we
have a hypothesis but it's not been
tested
then they could rework what they've
submitted but in general scientific
journals don't like to publish things
that don't claim to have results
if you didn't have a predictive
hypothesis in the first place then what
you've collected aren't data they're not
a test of anything
and the fact that many people who are
purportedly doing science don't
understand the distinction means that
some person at the Brookings Institute
with a PhD in something political
doesn't understand it maybe isn't that
surprising but it's going to destroy the
planet like you know this this level of
of
the combination of like deviousness and
ignorance is
devastating to discourse and to our
sense making like we cannot hope to make
our way through a landscape of lots of
different kinds of information coming at
us if we can't put a couple of simple
things in order and say I made an
observation
what are all the possible reasons that
thing could be true
okay I've got three possibilities
if possibility a let's call it a
hypothesis we're true what else would
necessarily be true that's prediction
that follows from hypothesis a same for
prediction that follows from hypothesis
B and C okay are these mutually
exclusive super easy and wonderful if
they are if they're not well the
predictions from A and B aren't really
exclusive but if C is if the prediction
from C is true then we've definitely
excluded those two and if one of these
is two we're still stuck with these two
and on and on it goes right
the
it's not that hard
School kills this in US
and apparently higher ed and the
credentials that most these people are
walking around with completely
obliterates the ability to Think Through
basic logic you have something yeah I've
got a couple things yeah one one of the
things that we have done
from the beginning on Dark Horse is
build up people's scientific toolkit
with principles that we rely on I don't
claim that they're necessarily finished
but there are a couple principles that
that belong here one principle is every
scientific paper
would describe its relationship to a
hypothesis and the relationship really
comes down to one of two things
either it's an observation which leads
to a hypothesis which then needs a test
or it is a test of a hypothesis that
exists now part of the problem as we've
talked about is that this is all on the
honor System and one of the way for
people who are pursuing a credential or
grant money to cheat is to pretend that
some observation they've made was
actually a test of a hypothesis that
they only came up with after oh look
what my data showed Oh I totally thought
that all along yeah yeah this was a test
of that thing that it's now shown to be
true so the honor System is a problem
here but when done properly you're doing
one of there's nothing wrong with not
having a pre-existing hypothesis but the
point is that says you're on step one
you're on the observation phase that's
right if you have observed and then you
want to go run a test you need a
hypothesis and you need to have that you
cannot test it uh with the observations
you've already made you could go back to
a data set and you could look for some
other pattern that you've now predicted
will exist there but you have to
actually run a new test otherwise it's
scientifically invalid right so anyway
that's the process that I can't get back
to your own data set like you can look
at other people's data
um and say you know you could query your
data set for something else you can't
query it for the observation that set
the process in motion you could look for
something else that you didn't know was
there or not there you could look for
some other correlation but the
clearly these people do not understand
the basics of how science works and it's
not you know children do scientific
thinking without having to be trained
they don't do it perfectly they don't do
it in a paparian way they're not
falsificationists but the point is
scientific thinking is natural and as
you say it's drummed out of us by bad
education but these people clearly
either don't know or don't care or both
right
the second piece of uh the toolkit I
want to point out somewhere in what you
read they do what Scott Adams calls mind
reading where they say that the reason
that we have used technical terms which
they don't understand Weinstein however
may have deployed this language to
appear to burnish the scientific Bona
fides of the hosts for a non-technical
audience is that the sentence you're
after yeah first of all for a bunch of
Humanity's morons that's not even good
English right
read it again
Weinstein however may have deployed this
language to appear to burnish the
scientific Bona fides of the hosts for a
non-technical audience appear to burnish
what they mean is burnish appeared to
burnish is the Revelation
right so you're not even doing Humanity
as well and it's you know that's a
pretty low bar but yeah
um okay here's the point
what are the chances that that
accusation would land on a podcast that
has the following thing as a piece of
toolkit which we have deployed and tried
to teach our audience repeatedly what's
happening the distinction between jargon
and terms of art yeah yeah now what we
say is that terms of art are a necessary
evil if you're working on something
technical you will probably need some
terms that are not straightforward this
should be minimized you want as few of
those things as possible you want them
as straightforward as possible but if
you're working on technical material
it's probably not going to be zero
you're going to have to make some terms
that are technical that need to be
described explicitly
jargon is the abuse of the fact that you
might need technical terms to do
technical work to keep people out to
keep them from knowing what you're
talking about it is the use of
unnecessarily complex language in order
to limit the discussion to only insiders
right that is not a necessary evil
that's just simply an evil so the idea
that they're going to accuse us of using
language because like correlation right
yeah exactly hypothesis yeah that's
definitely us using jargon there
[Music]
foreign